that was a little too easy you're really
going to have to get closer to him you
can't give him the old type of open look
beautiful pea tears
nice at the pocket Alex laughs Trey
working with Dettman started with trade
young breaking down to defense a ten
point two assists start for Troy young
Kevin murder in Collins as well nice
pocket bounce up and down first period
on
the LOB right there easy dunk
you only do who ralph was at the boys
law was law old me on mine so dis a
great career for a big confident in
himself and when you turn down the 85
million dollar deal in the subway
are you pretty confident they're
shooting in the 54:15 positive they're
on the offensive glass
you know the hawk took the advantage
over undersides lineup that the clip was
put on the floor and that was the
difference jorian friend almost got you
know a wide open three for Lin betrayed
young he's head eighth game tonight
tre fights college all alone Mike Scott
festering tre will drive kicked finds
college again
these two get along well you 20 to go to
point Hockley trade maneuvers finds Alex
land wait
[Applause]